oh look at this rated gene movie well
this looks very this looks very good
yeah
i like this g-movie and can you put that
in there because i cause i want to know
what martin scorsese has done
are most great stories and outsider
story
uh i don't know i mean i feel like i
feel like i'm an outsider and i feel
like
almost everyone i know feels like an
outsider at some point in their life if
not often probably more than 50 of the
time
so maybe that's why we can kind of
gravitate toward outsider stories
um
yeah and it you know it's
we look at us
film like mean girls or something it's
it's about people just trying to be
together and fit in it's we have this
urge to we have this urge to be together
and part of the tribe and so
uh
the the id the outsider story is fun to
play with but i don't think any of us
want to be an outsider but it's fun to
watch the outsider because we kind of
can we feel like we're outsiders
does that make sense it does i'm trying
to think of the movie i just watched
from the is it pump up the volume the
christian slave oh yeah yeah and so here
he's this radio
guy
and everybody kind of worships him
because he just says whatever he wants
yeah and they can't believe what they're
hearing and then you know the the
faculty is just incensed by it
and then in real life
he's this awkward guy that
he wants he he wants to be part of the
group but then he's kind of turned off
by that whole suburbia high school
hierarchy thing
and um
just had me thinking about that just
sort of this guy that actually when you
listen to him
he spoke to everyone
but then
for whatever reason he was too scared at
the the high school to yeah try to
navigate the
social hierarchy yeah
and um
but but we we have these these hero
stories
where
are they always the outsider i guess
maybe that's what makes the the hero's
arc
is that
i guess yeah i guess in order for
i mean for the most part
when you know we have our heroes journey
and i think
it's a
singular hero um i think it's because
we could we can relate
to the problems of one person for 90
minutes
um
if you bring in too many people
or you know the the ensemble cast there
tends to be a veering towards the one
person that's really pushing it all the
way through
um
so we we have to have that we also
almost have to have that mirror who's my
mirror here oh it's cameron diaz okay
great
i'm with her on this journey
um and that's and i don't think that's
real life in any way at all
but for um
well we're all our own heroes in our own
journeys but we're also collective but
so
i guess our protagonist is an outsider
of sorts because the protagonist needs
to be spun around they need to be pushed
back on their heels
and
that's why we're interested it's just
like oh wait they spun around they're
dizzy how do they stop being dizzy
okay
that's fun now how do i turn the page or
sit here
uh for another 10 minutes to find out
what the next two scenes are because
that was interesting
what peril is this character going to be
in so
yeah it would make sense that the
characters would be outsiders this um
you know during covid we we have all
these uh the the movies i've watched
have not been movies i would watch you
know there are comfort movies and the
wrong missy came out the david spade
movie
um that adam sandler produced
and um and it's not a movie i'd go run
to see but i watched it and it's just um
he is he is an outsider he's he's in his
own tragedy it's a comedy but he's in
the utter tragedy
of
thinking that he found the you know it's
it's really formulaic and like you like
if i just told you two or three
description you'd be like oh so the act
one is this act two is exactly as this
it's like yeah it is but it's fun to
watch them get there
what movie protagonists do do you feel
the most um
connection to
could be male or female
well so when i was young and this was uh
there was this movie called johnny suede
brad pitt starred in it that came out
and tom dichillo wrote it and i look at
it now and it's absurd and it's
hilarious
but at the time
i was i thought i was johnny suede
i am
it's it was brad pitt's first leading
role and um
and
it's just about a guy
who's trying to figure out love and
wants to get a band together
i'm like that's me
and it's just kind of silly because it's
a um he's really kind of a dopey
character and not you know i i don't
know why i
gravitated to him so much i think i
think it was because i was trying to
figure out love and um
you know was kind of always wanted to
have you know getting a band together is
like getting group of friends together
just like how do we how do we how do a
bunch of guys you know
um come together and uh you know
not make love well let's just get a band
it's
it's everything's kind of intimacy so he
was trying to find his intimacy and
blowing it beyond belief and
um
so when i think of a character that uh i
gravitated to
when i was uh when i was young it was it
was johnny suede and i had the
uh yeah it's tom dichillo um
i got to interview him like 15 years ago
and he's written books too and i brought
every single book i'm like please sign
my books now he lives in la
so uh i i still have to
like uh yeah anyway he's he's a i'm a
huge fan of his and
i'm a huge fan of how honesty is about
um
his career as a filmmaker and how
really rough and tumble it was
and um
just the beauty of johnny sway in his
other movie living in oblivion which
came out after that
and sorry you were still in the church
at the time you saw it okay yeah were
and you didn't tell anyone that you saw
the movie i was very careful yeah
because it was rated r
oh so i had to go to the video store
actually i think i bought the vhs i
bought the vhs and that and i i watched
that thing
that's probably the movie i've seen the
most in my life
um
and i could probably uh give you every
line of dialogue from here the reason i
watched it was because uh one of my
favorite singers is in it nick cave so
that was what turned me onto it and then
all of a sudden i'm like well that
character spoke to me so wow would you
hide the movie somewhere
yes yeah yeah hide the hide the movies
hide the records
um
yeah
where would you hide them
um if not to i i actually had my own
apartment at that time so
so it was easy enough but when i was
like still living at home it was records
behind the dresser and we would make
mixed tapes for our friends and then
we'd hide the mixtapes
but we would all trade the tapes and
then we'd keep the records at certain
friends houses uh move them back and
forth
wow and it's just because they were
rated r that was for music and that's
because they were punk rock and that was
something that would um that no one
would understand uh
um
movies i know movies i wouldn't even
bring into the house that were rated r
um but i would try to i would i would go
to the video store and this was this is
when i was married i'd go to the video
store and then i would like look around
to make sure no one from the
congregation was around and then i would
like
you know and then i'd pick up oh look at
this rated g movie well this looks very
this looks very good yeah
i like this g movie can you put that in
there because i cuz i want to know what
martin scorsese's done
and then um
yeah then i went to the library
constantly and
was just checking out every movie that
you know
stuff like i'd never seen apocalypse now
and it's just i never and i didn't know
what a war movie was i thought war movie
was just violence and terrible and it's
just like
oh no these are crafted films and so
but i would have to watch them on my own
and be very careful yeah